اكثر من ملياري فرد في العالم يتعذر عليهم
الحصول على المياه الصالحه للشرب ليس مجرد
رقم بل حقيقه تعمل الامم المتحده على
اذكاء الوعي بشانها من اجل اتخاذ اجراءات
لمعالجه ازمه المياه العالميه فالمطلوب
تسريع التغيير لحل ازمه المياه والصرف
الصحي الا ان الخلل الوظيفي الذي تعاني
منه الدوره المائيه يقوض التقدم المحرز في
جل القضايا العالميه الرئيسيه كصحه والامن
الغذائي والمساوات بين الجنسين والتوظيف
والتعليم والصناعه والسلام تقول ارقام
منظمه الصحه العالميه ومنظمه اليونيسف
ومنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه انما
يقرب من مليون و400 الف فرد
يموتون بسبب الامراض المرتبطه بالمياه وان
واحدا من كل اربعه افراد اي ما يعادل
مليارين حول العالم يفتقرون الى خدمات
مياه الشرب المامونه فيما يفتقر نصف سكان
العالم اي 3 مليارات
مليون فرد الى مرافق الصرف الصحي المداره
بامان ولا يعالج بطريقه امنه سوى
44% فقط من مياه الصرف الصحي المنزليه ومن
المتوقع ان يرتفع طلب المياه على الصعيد
العالمي بنسبه
55% بحلول عام 2050
الدول العربيه لا تجد حلولا مؤكده لتفادي
تداعيات الفقر المائي وتشير التقارير
الحكوميه وتقارير المنظمات الدوليه الى
تضرر معظم دول الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
بما فيها سوريا والعراق ومصر والسودان
وغيرها من الدول التي تتميز بوجود نهر او
اكثر من نهر فيها ينصب تركيز الامم
المتحده على دعم الهدف السادس من اهداف
التنميه المستدامه الذي يعالج مساله اتاحه
المياه ومرافق الصرف الصحي للجميع مع حلول
عام 2030 كما اطلقت الامم المتحده حمله كن
ان تتغيير العالميه لتشجيع الجميع على
اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه في حياتهم
اليوميه لتغيير اساليبهم في استخدام
المياه واستهلاكها وادا ارتها ويبقى
السؤال ما اذا كانت الالتزامات الطوعيه
هذه الى جانب الالتزامات التي تعرضها
الحكومات والشركات والمنظمات
والتحالفات
ستوفر سبيلا عمليا كافيا لابعاد شبح
العطشي عن البشريه